anteriormente vimos el enlace carbono
hidrógeno y calculamos el número de onda
aproximado en el que esperamos que
aparezca la señal del estiramiento de
ese enlace en el espectro y r el número
de onda que obtuvimos es ligeramente
mayor a 3000 sin embargo ese número
depende de la hibridación del carbón
veamos algunos ejemplos observen que en
este caso el carbono tiene una
hibridación esp porque tiene un triple
enlace así que tenemos un enlace carbono
hidrógeno en donde el carbono tiene una
hibridación esp y la señal para el
estiramiento de este enlace se encuentra
aproximadamente en un número de onda
igual a 3300
en el siguiente ejemplo el carbono tiene
un doble enlace así que tiene una
hibridación espetos entonces tenemos un
enlace carbono hidrógeno en donde el
carbono tiene una hibridación sp2 y la
señal para el estiramiento de este
enlace aparece a los 3100 números de
onda
finalmente observen que en el último
caso sólo tenemos enlaces simples así
que este carbono tiene una hibridación
sp3 tenemos un enlace carbono hidrógeno
en donde el carbono tiene una
hibridación sp3 y la señal para el
estiramiento de este enlace aparece
aproximadamente a los 2900 números de
onda
entonces como explicamos la diferencia
entre estos números de ondas
todos son enlaces carbono hidrógeno
bueno hay que tomar en cuenta la
hibridación si analizamos el carbono con
hibridación sp eso significa que
contiene un 50 por ciento del orbital s
mientras que para el orbital con
hibridación sp2 tenemos un 33 por ciento
del orbital s y para el orbital con
hibridación sp3 sólo tenemos el 25 por
ciento entonces si regresamos al carbono
con hibridación esp ya dijimos que tiene
un 50 por ciento del orbital s eso
significa que la densidad electrónica se
encuentra más cerca del núcleo y como
estamos hablando de este enlace entonces
es el más corto y por lo tanto debe ser
el más fuerte este enlace carbono
hidrógeno sp
es más fuerte que el enlace donde el
carbono tiene una hibridación sp2 y como
este enlace tiene más porcentaje del
orbital s que éste es más fuerte si
recuerdan el vídeo anterior la fuerza
del enlace afecta a la constante de
fuerza o constante elástica acá así que
al aumentar la fuerza del enlace
aumentamos acá y vimos que al aumentar k
aumenta la frecuencia o número de onda
en el que encontraremos la señal en el
espectro y r
entonces como este es el enlace más
fuerte por eso tiene un número de onda
más alto muy bien ahora que ya
entendimos esta idea de la hibridación
analicemos algunos espectros de red de
los hidrocarburos
primero comparemos alcanos y algunos
aquí tenemos dos espectros
el primero corresponde a la molécula
decano y el segundo corresponde al 1 oct
y no aquí tenemos un triple enlace
entonces veamos cuáles son las
diferencias algo que ayuda mucho es
dibujar una línea que pase por los 3000
números de onda sabemos que la señal de
estiramiento del enlace carbono
hidrógeno en donde el carbono tiene una
hibridación sp3 aparece antes de 3000
por eso es tan útil dibujar esta línea
así que la señal que buscamos es esta no
vamos a analizarla detenidamente además
mi dibujo no es perfecto pero pensemos
en que nos encontramos antes de 3000
aquí esperamos una señal para el enlace
carbono hidrógeno en donde el carbono
tiene una hibridación sp3 entonces
comparemos la región de diagnóstico con
la de
huella dactilar si dibujamos una línea
que separe a las dos regiones podemos
ver que en la región de diagnóstico solo
tenemos esta señal que corresponde al
enlace carbono hidrógeno donde el
carbono tiene una hibridación sp3 este
es un espectro muy sencillo ahora veamos
el espectro del uno obstinó aquí tenemos
la misma señal porque en esta molécula
también tenemos enlaces carbono
hidrógeno en donde el carbono tiene una
hibridación sp3 entonces al dibujar una
línea en 3000 podemos ver algunas
diferencias por ejemplo esta señal que
se encuentra en un número de ondas
cercano a 3300 porque aquí es 3.100 3200
y 3300 regresemos al inicio
observen que a los 3300 números de onda
esperamos encontrar una señal para el
estiramiento del enlace carbono
hidrógeno en donde el carbono tiene una
hibridación esp esa es la señal que
encontramos entonces esta señal
corresponde al enlace carbono hidrógeno
donde el carbono tiene una hibridación
esp que sería esta parte de la molécula
aquí tenemos un carbono y un hidrógeno y
por acá tenemos otro carbono así que la
señal corresponde a este enlace carbono
hidrógeno y el carbono tiene una
hibridación esp muy bien para este al
'chino' también tenemos esta señal que
aparece en la región de diagnóstico esta
señal se encuentra en un número de onda
de aproximadamente 2100
ya un poco más y corresponde al
estiramiento del triple enlace esta es
la señal del triple enlace carbono
carbono del que hablamos en el vídeo
anterior esta es la región en nuestro
espectro que corresponde al triple
enlace recuerden que la región de huella
dactilar es única para cada molécula
pero nos ayuda a ver las diferencias y
así poder analizar el espectro veamos
otro y tratemos de compararlo con estos
este es el espectro r de un al que no
corresponde al uno externo entonces
primero dibujemos una línea a los 1500
números de onda y después dibujemos una
línea a los 3000 sabemos que esta señal
corresponde al enlace carbono hidrógeno
donde el carbono tiene una hibridación
sp3 pero
cuál sería esta bueno esta señal se
encuentra aproximadamente en 3100 y
corresponde al enlace carbono hidrógeno
donde el carbono tiene una hibridación
sp2 su estiramiento ocurre en este
número de onda o frecuencia y sabíamos
que había un carbono con hibridación sp2
porque tenemos este doble enlace pero
observen que esta señal aparece a los
3100 números de onda mientras que esta
señal aparece a los 3.300 así que
dibujar una línea y analizar el número
de onda en el que aparecen las señales
nos ayuda mucho a distinguir las
diferencias en el espectro
en qué número de onda aparece esta señal
bueno si dibujamos una línea aquí
tenemos 1.500 1.600 y 1.700 aparece
aproximadamente a los 1650 en el vídeo
anterior dijimos que esta región
corresponde al doble enlace así que esta
señal corresponde al estiramiento del
doble enlace que tenemos en nuestra
molécula entonces si comparamos estos
dos espectros recuerden que un triple
enlace vibra más rápido que un doble
enlace por lo tanto la señal aparece en
un número de onda más alto mientras que
como el doble enlace no vibra tan rápido
la señal aparece en un número de onda
menor
finalmente comparemos el espectro del al
que no con el de un harén o en este caso
tenemos al tolueno
dibujamos una línea a los 3000 números
de onda podemos ver que esta señal
aparece antes de los 3000 corresponde al
estiramiento de un enlace carbono
hidrógeno donde el carbono tiene una
hibridación sp3 y si analizamos el
tolueno este carbono tiene una
hibridación sp3 ahora también tenemos
esta pequeña señal que está ligeramente
después de 3000 se encuentra
aproximadamente a los 3100 y ya sabemos
que corresponde al estiramiento de un
enlace carbono hidrógeno donde el
carbono tiene una hibridación espetos
aproximadamente en 3.100 observen que
esta situación es muy parecida a ésta
muy bien ahora veamos la región del
doble enlace dibujaré una línea en 1600
y trataré de conectarla con el otro
espectro aquí tenemos la señal del doble
enlace carbón o carbón pero cuando
hablamos del estiramiento de un doble
enlace en un anillo aromático
generalmente la señal aparece antes de
los 1600 aquí parece que tenemos dos
señales así que depende mucho del
compuesto que tengamos en este caso la
señal aparece entre 1600 y 1450 y
también tenemos otras señales por
ejemplo esta parte que no la tenemos en
el espectro de arriba al igual que estas
señales que tampoco aparece hablaremos
de lo que significan estas señales en
otro vídeo pero lo más importante a
tomar en cuenta es que esta señal
carbono carbon del compuesto aroma
y aparece en un número de onda más bajo
que este entonces sólo observen las
diferentes señales que aparecen y que
como en este caso nos indican que
tenemos un anillo de benceno esta fue
una introducción rápida a los espectros
y erc de los hidrocarburos